on parle si vous voulez bien d'un autre
sujet qui peut être une fête news je ne
sais pas vous savez que steve banane qui
a été l'un des artisans de la victoire
et donald trump parce que c'est l'un des
théoriciens du populisme qui a amené au
pouvoir l'actuel président des états
unis
si bayonne vient assez régulièrement en
france il est en ce moment à paris donne
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'interviews et ils
se cachent pas ils ne cachent pas pardon
son souhait est de voir marine le pen
faire un très bon score aux européennes
est ce que pour autant il sert les
intérêts des états unis ou simplement
l'intérêt de ses propres idées qu'on
peut appeler populistes ou nationalistes
écoutez le point de vue d'edouard
philippe le premier ministre était hier
dans un facebook live du conte en marche
pour l'élection européenne et pour lui
ce type banane est un homme vraiment
dangereux il vient faire campagne et
participe à une campagne bros et puis
surtout il dit que son intérêt à lui au
président trump c'est que madame le pen
gagne parce que parce que parce que
c'est l'intérêt d'un courant d'idées
dans lequel ils classent le président
américain et qui lui semble de nature à
faire prévaloir les intérêts j'imagine
assez peu les intérêts de la france et
j'imagine donc plutôt les intérêts des
états unis
alors là où le sujet est intéressant
c'est que sipan lui-même ne répond pas
non à cet argument il dit ben oui c'est
vrai une victoire des populistes en
europe ça sert le président trump et les
états unis
il l'a dit ce matin c'était chez nos
confrères de bfm tv
je crois que si lille et lé mouvement
souverainiste population lisbonne sera
val saint père évidemment ça va aider
ces mouvements à travers le monde
ce sera utile
on avait entendu ça augmente ce type
aussi avec la france 1 soumises dont on
disait qu'elle était trop proche de
moscou qu'elle servait les intérêts
russes avant servait les intérêts
français
mais je ferai savoir de quoi on parle
c'est quoi le populisme ça fait
plusieurs fois qu'on a eu ce débat ce
débat ici je pense qu'on a pas le temps
pour le pour le régler mais dans le cas
de la france a soumises
je ne suis plus mais il ya moins de
relations avec les oligarques russes que
dans l'équipe rapprochée de monsieur
macron ce que visiblement la faire bénir
la crasse ou aller très loin là aussi et
c'est pas un fait que nous avec des
oligarques russes qui financent
je-ne-sais-quoi au tchad dans des mines
d'or avec toute une série de massacres
salaire salaire magnifique cette
histoire encore ils sont pas populiste
donc quand vous êtes un mauvais procès
qu'on a essayé c'est un très mauvais
procès on fait face ici quelqu'un a les
mains prises en cambouis avec une
puissance étrangère mais il ya des lois
et il doit être sanctionné mais c'est
étonnant de le penser a priori
et puis en inde
le bjp de me dit qu'il a gagné c'est il
est dirigé par qui par moscou par trempe
c'est un ultra populiste par exemple et
puis pourquoi on parle pas des
populistes de pologne ou d'ukraine qui
sont plus proches des intérêts européens
ils sont dirigés par qui eux à
washington par par par pari par pas
berlin et puis qu'est ce que c'est que
le populisme encore une fois je pose la
question
imaginons par exemple que vous soyez en
grèce que vous soyez un citoyen grec a
subi le mémorandum de 2015 ou les eaux
pour le taux de mortalité augmente on
peut pas être soigné il faut venir avec
son propre commissaire allemand de
l'union européenne d'une politique
rigoureuse audiences publiques en grèce
pour réduire la dette qui depuis a
augmenté mais les services publics ont
disparu et au point qu'ils vendent le
parthénon c'est pour un citoyen grec
ça va pas très bien et bien 6 si le
citoyen grec 10 10 est il donc ces
allemands ils sont un peu gonflé quand
même parce qu'en 1947
on leur a nulle alors dette pour qu'ils
puissent se reconstruire mais par contre
ils nous ont toujours pas rendu leurs
volées par les nazis
c'est ultra populistes comme propos mais
c'est une bonne flic new c'est
parfaitement vrai et en plus ça serait
vraiment légitime
parce que ça ça rembourser entièrement
leur dette non mais c'est un exemple on
peut en faire plein kirchner non mais
kirchner il est il et il est populiste
donc les politiques de kirchner en
argentine qui ont été suivis longtemps
et soutenus sont pas sont pas légitimes
celle de thomas sankara pareil voilà
populiste et le brésil etc on peut aller
non mais je reste je repose la question
différemment lorsqu'on signal est ce que
est ce que avoir les mêmes idées que
trump ou que poutine
c'est forcément être servir les intérêts
de trump et de poutine l'européen moi
j'ai pas du tout les mêmes
interrogations de vocabulaire que vous
il ya des peu importe d'ailleurs comme
on les appelle on les appelle ce que
j'identifie c'est qu'un courant
international au pouvoir d'un certain
nombre de pays et qui a en commun des
deux prôné des régimes autoritaires anti
d2 qui tirent là qui tire un trait anti
démocratique c'est-à-dire qu'ils pensent
que la démocratie n'est pas un sujet
aujourd'hui car climato-sceptiques
hostile aux droits des femmes en
particulier droit à l'avortement et
homophobe
ces gens là existent il existe au brésil
aux états unis en russie en pologne
hongrie et j'oubliais aussi qu'ils
étaient anti migrants pardon j'ai oublié
sa part du rail ont de vous monsieur
françois hollande en 2009 a fait le
backup d'un coup d'état
oui j'ai par exemple non mais c'est pas
le sujet ça parce que je n'ai pas
d'idées mais les applaudir au service 2
c'est cette fois il existe elle est au
pouvoir dans un ensemble de pays que je
viens de citer et probablement dans
d'autres et dans d'autres pays où elle
n'est pas au pouvoir il y à des réseaux
actifs qui sont candidats à des
élections pour gagner des élections
bien entendu tous ces gens là qui sont
participe de la même très grande famille
qui a déjà le vent en poupe sont à
planète aujourd'hui on a connu des
périodes où c'était l'heure où c'étaient
les sociaux démocrates les libertés les
livres y avait le vent en poupe
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui le
mouvement
il est sociaux démocrates il est en leur
faveur
peut-être
du mois ces packs a moins d'argent
public pourra voir nice on sait que les
cadres nationaux ne permettent plus de
dégager l'argent public qui permettait
auparavant de ces coriaces il laurent
sociaux parce qu'il a compris que pour
être longue sur ce sujet je vous dis oui
parce que c'est un sujet passionnant
mais ces passionnés y adjoignent
abandonne votre point je vous laisse la
parole
évidemment c'est pas de marchands mais
de la porte la donne aux internautes 60%
d'entre vous considère que non les
populistes ne sont pas aux ordres de
moscou de washington ou des deux et puis
ce ce commentaire de babineau le mot
populisme me dérange pour décrire banane
et le rassemblement national car il ya
aussi un populisme de gauche comme la
france insoumise banane est un
nationaliste oui c'était pas de
marchands koupéla puis il ya une version
un pragmatique de toute cette agitation
on est au milieu d'une grande guerre
commerciale dans laquelle les chine les
etats-unis et l'europe se battre les uns
contre les autres et évidemment du point
de vue des chinois et des américains
tout ce qui peut affaiblir la puissance
européenne s'appelle que l'europe c'est
un tiers des exportations mondiales
c'est énorme et et sur le plan du
commerce international sur le plan de la
concurrence
l'europe existe vraiment aller quasiment
fédéral est donc tout ce qui peut servir
à affaiblir cette gigantesque machine
sera fait et toutes les opérations en ce
moment c'est ça relève de ça et
effectivement banon a raison ça sert les
intérêts de trump au sens commercial du
terme car il divise en espérant régner
je vous donne juste le point de vue de
marine le pen ou plutôt c'est pas moi
qui vous le donne c'est elle
c'était ce matin sur france info et elle
assume tout à fait sa proximité avec
subban
permettez moi c'est un conseiller
politique au caire en l'accompagnement
intéressant qu'on sait petit peu
d'hésitation les etats-unis sont en
train de faire le choix de tourner le
dos à la mondialisation sauvage c'est
évidemment que ça nous intéresse de la
même manière que l'inde est en train de
mettre en place une politique
protectionniste de défense de l'identité
parce que nous partageons cette idée que
le monde est en train de changer et de
tourner le dos à toute une série de
diktat qui ont été imposées depuis 30
ans bien sûr que nous discutons
politique les babouins si on reste sur
le registre économique
l'argument stéphane marchand
consistant à dire de déstructurer
l'europe c'est objectivement servir les
gens qui ne rêvent que d'y pénétrer plus
avant comme les etats-unis ou la chine
d'un point de vue commercial il faut
hélas se souvenir que depuis 1945 la
france n'est plus on pourrait dire un
interlocuteur mais un lieu de champ de
bataille c'est à dire un endroit où
l'est et l'ouest sont tiraillés
aujourd'hui on pourrait dire la plaque
asie-pacifique peut-être aussi
aujourd'hui la russie c'est vrai qu'on
est un lieu un marché encore intéressant
pour un moment heureusement donc que les
gens ce que les gens se disputent donc
il ya effectivement des batailles
d'influencé et depuis le début on sait
très bien que les états unis voient d'un
mauvais oeil les états unis d'europe
potentiel et seront très heureux de voir
des européens
désunie cela étant moi je vois plutôt
que l'on pourrait dire une construction
qui pourrait être manoeuvrés de lin ou
d'un côté ou de l'autre de l'atlantique
moi je vois plutôt dans ce mot cette
montée des populismes d'ailleurs ce type
banane c'est intéressant à ce matin dans
un média français riz la filature mais
complètement et de l'assumer
cette étiquette qui au départ est un peu
péjorative de populiste qui en fait anti
élitiste antilibérale et effectivement
nationaliste on voit bien que ça monte
dans tous les pays c'est la conséquence
malheureusement de l'effondrement des
classes moyennes de cette polarisation
des sociétés qui est lié à ce nouveau
siècle numérique est en train de se
développer et qui s'accroît avec des
populations en souffrance ou quand même
bien le dire c'est une marche encore un
point sur l'économie le déficit
commercial de l'europe avec la chine
l'année dernière c'était 184 milliards
d'euros donc est ce qu'on peut dire
aussi mais c'est l'europe d'aujourd'hui
qui est qui et qui est trop faible
avec la chine et qu'il ferait mieux de
se protéger davantage alors nous sommes
en excédent par ailleurs avec les états
unis
donc
oui enfin ça c'est une europe et la
chine ne sont pas tout à fait au même
stade de leur développement industriel
et par conséquent les biens que nous
leur achetons les bientôt l'abandon ne
seront pas exactement de même nature
mais pour revenir à l'argument d'olivier
babeau à l'instant ça n'est pas
tellement trump cette politique dure
depuis comme vous le dites très bien
depuis 50 ans trump en est une
expression vociférante mais cette
méthode existe de manière plus subtile
en général avec tous les administrations
américaines
oui les influences étrangères
tout se passe comme si depuis que tu
rends pas été élu il y aurait une
influence spécifique nouvelles des etats
unis
mais je suis désolé les états unis par
exemple nous empêche de vendre le
meilleur sinon le deuxième meilleur
meilleur avion de combat rafale
ils vendent leurs casseroles volante que
le f-35 et coûtent une fortune en
faisant une pression en particulier sur
tous les pays européens et le font déjà
depuis bien longtemps bush et obama
le dispositif de défense européen est
entièrement calibré sur le temps c'est
l'otan et qui le commande et blocs sous
la présidence françois hollande c'est
bien les etats-unis qui ont bloqué le
développement des des drones de combat
français pour signer des contrats avec
les drones acheter des drones mâle et
reaper qui sont sous contrôle toujours
états unis même quand ils sont achetés
par la france alors que le président
françois hollande était été écouté par
la nsa aidé en cela par l'allemagne
qu'est-ce qu'ils imposent comme système
d'exploitation au nouveau ministère de
balard windows franchement il ya un
moment on se demande mais ils sont sous
influence ou quoi et tous ces gens là
font ont fait partie d'une association
enfin finie tant que plutôt d'une
officine d'affluence french american
foundation et encore une fois j'ai dit
plusieurs fois ici imaginait que la
moitié de nos ministres soient passés
par là du corps social franco russe le
franco-chinois on en trouvera sa 4ème
année bizarre
propose à des jeunes professionnels au
potentiel une connaissance plus plus
intime que les emmènent leur ferrand
compass l'insee 9 usines de florange
j'arrive pas totalement tout comprendre
dans cette affaire parce que à la fois
j'observe que tout in et trump ont des
conceptions quand même très site très
voisines du monde des libertés du
national de leur nationalisme de
protectionnisme ils sont très très
similaire et en même temps je les
imagine bien que ils s'affrontent sur ce
terrain sur ce terrain de chasse qu'elle
a frank est qu'est l'europe et qu'elle
est qu'est la france et donc je trouve
ça assez angoissant en fait que
s'affrontent deux deux géants ils sont
plus les seuls maintenant sur les deux
géants d'accord sur le type de société
qu'ils voudraient les uns et les autres
nous imposer et voilà je voulais vous
faire part de cette remarque qui
n'apporte pas grand chose au débat qu
peut-être mais si c'est intéressant ça
me fera parce qu au moins avant quand on
aime la guerre froide il y avait les
états unis et l'union soviétique en
avait deux projets de société
voilà maintenant ils sont d'accord oui
oui mais c'est pas qu'on les états unis
la loue la constitution n'a pas changé
aux etats unis c'est juste trump il ya
un et trahi il ya des gens qui sont élus
il ya des vrais projets et commercial
est pour l'instant et on attend ça
réussit plutôt bien aux états unis en
tout cas d'un point de vue économique
et puis le font depuis longtemps le
protectionnisme ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé quand problème merci aux états
unis quand on en est à sept ou huit ndar
aux américains qui viennent de revenir
sur le droit à l'avortement
on voit bien que le commerce des facs de
commerce et l'idéologie dans la vie pour
que les peuples soutiennent des projets
faut aussi aller leur parler de ce qui
les intéresse
voilà et je trouve que c'est quand même
chose qu'en russie juste parce qu'il a
trop merci oui on se garde encore
quelques minutes si vous le voulez bien
pour parler d'un produit mythique le
choco bn peut-être que vous en avez
mangé pour votre goûter en autres